for those that do know I love supporting
local Brands and if you didn't know
we're from Sunny Singapore the
birthplace of the thumb drive Brands
like Razer creative secret lab and so
much more with CEST audio coming into
the full with the kagami true wireless
earbuds off the bat they look pretty
good with an interesting earbud design
which I'll get into in a bit the case is
sort of solid and I say sort because the
top is much harder plastic than the
bottom half but it doesn't feel fragile
this comes in two colors we've got
midnight blue and elegant copper which
is hours and they have this Leather
Pouch available with a slot at the back
to put in the USBC cable so that's cool
the kagami or kagami is depending on who
you ask houses 1dd plus 1ba hybrid
drivers and play for up to 8 hours on
the butts and up to 40 hours with the
case that charges via USBC it has
Bluetooth 5.3 and it weighs in at 2.4 G
for each shell so they feel comfy over
long periods of time it's also ipx5
water resistant and zerz also boasts
that he has four CVC 8.0 entc
microphones for Clear calls so let's put
that to the test real quick we are in a
r dis Street in Singapore this is how
the Ki this sound like and let me know
what you guys think of the audio in the
comments below but is how it sounds like
this how it the environment around you
and again this is how they sound like
soundwise they're actually pretty decent
kind of comparable to my Sony wf1000xm
3S from 2019 there's a nice Rumble in
the base and the mids and highs don't
get drowned out by the base in any sense
listening to lavander haes by Taylor
Swift these actually do a good job in
the base Department while delivering
crisp vocals TOS goodbye performed well
with these as well in picking out the
detail in the plucking of the acoustic
guitar and the resonance from these
symbols heavier stuff like in the
trenches by dying fetus or deep in the
willow by knock loose could use a little
boost in the mids and highs you can
listen to most geners on these but
expect to change up the EQ either in
Spotify or your phone because this pair
of yots does not come with an app to ch
change up stuff overall they sound good
for most genres but you'll still need to
go out of your way to tweak things like
the EQ one thing to not is that the
Bluetooth codex are limited to SBC and
EAC and nothing higher which I honestly
don't have a problem with but if you're
more of an uptight audio file when it
comes to your music formats I would
rather you st clear and look elsewhere
for earbuds if you're even looking for
earbuds I know most of you just use IM
IMS anyway for good measure I also
played a round or two of radio not with
these on and they definitely work well
for gaming with picking up voices and
directions of footsteps and if they do
well for PC gaming imagine how they'd
fair for mobile gaming especially when
you're comfy in a secret lab chair here
at geek culture we've tested plenty of
chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
fourman function helps the Titan Evo
2022 deliver the best seating experience
like no other for more information check
out secretlab.co now with all that out
of the way there are a couple things
that zest has done well with the kagami
and there are definitely things that I
hope you can look into especially since
a pair goes for $199 Singapore dollars
at the time of recording and yes I know
the screenshot shows that it's on sale
but sales end so zest has been touting
the comfort of these earbuds and by God
I can actually say they are super
comfortable they're like second to the
Galaxy bu 2 Pros what I was worried
about are these little hooks in their
design when we thought the images I
thought man I hope they don't turn out
like Marshall's miners which hurt to put
on but I spent money on it already and I
lost the receipt they hooking your ear
pretty well and the seal on the ear tips
are good enough to keep out the clicky
Clacks of an office at 50% volume for me
anything lower and you hear Mouse clicks
when it comes to commuting if you're not
blasting the earphones at 70% volume and
higher you're definitely going to pick
up more voices and the sound of the
trains and buses especially when you're
hitting underground which leads me into
the fact that it doesn't have any any
form of ENT on these these creative
sense more s reminder that it's another
Singapore company I've been using them
as a backup for my headphones that havec
in it and for a much lower price
compared to the Zer kagami and that goes
for a lot of other brands out there who
may not have the bestc but at the very
least there's something to keep out
noise at all R pressure levels it's not
a major grip but I can get pushing for
the best audio experience like what Zer
is doing with the kagami while leaving
the entc bits aside there are valid
arguments on both ends but I would still
up for something that gives me ENC as an
option that and I wish they had an app
not only to adjust the EQ but to update
its firmware because in the time I've
had it it would randomly start and stop
songs with the touch input chime ringing
out even though I am nowhere close to
them and this mostly happens when
nothing is playing at 30 to 60c
intervals which is kind of weird besides
that connectivity is great thanks to
Bluetooth 5.3 in there and when
connecting to a pet device both devices
connect pretty much instantaneously
there were hardly any signal drops and
even if there were they get back on just
as quickly so no issues there last thing
I want to point out is the formatting on
the box let me go get the box all right
oh box look this is probably a defect
but my inner designer needs me to point
out that the lines underlined and it's
so close to the left side of the
packaging I think this is a great start
for zores because they have a good thing
going with how comfortable they are and
the fact that they sound pretty damn
decent for most genres in general the
microphone bits are leaving that to the
rest of youall to decide because I would
still prefer the microphone on my phone
to call or an actual microphone because
I really end that spoiled here it's just
the fact thatc is almost a key
requirement now for most consumers and I
get zerest isn't aiming for most people
but I hope the next iteration see some
changes I mentioned or something better
because it's always exciting when you
see companies in your country release
cool stuff and I would want them to find
their fo thing properly at some point
anyway let me know what you think about
the kagami true Wess eot so far leave
your question questions in the comments
below and if you like what we do maybe
follow us on all of our socials right
here to keep up to date with everything
we do we post news and content daily
make sure to hit that like And subscribe
buttons it goes a long way in keeping
the lights on here and have a great
weekend I'll catch youall soon if you
want to see more stuff check this
[Music]
out
he